gracias por continuar en la falta de
pantalla de france 24 estamos de regreso
con las principales noticias en materia
económico junto a nuestro compañero luis
mendez zúrich louis vamos a comenzar
hablando de un problema global no que
preocupa a todo el mundo muchísimos
países tiene que ver con la crisis en lo
que es la cadena de suministro que se
presentan muchos países así es santiago
pasa que como una consecuencia de la
pandemia de ccoo y 19 se han producido
entre otras cosas atascos en los puertos
y a su vez productos que no llegan
además de falta de materias primas y
fábricas que han tenido que detener sus
operaciones todo ello ha generado
escasez de productos terminados y ha
estado presionando a la inflación en
algunos países lo que debemos de tomar
en cuenta es que de acuerdo con la
publicación cuarto el fenómeno si bien
viene impactando recientemente no es
nuevo y desde hace mucho tiempo o poco
más de un año el economista stephen
roach venía advirtiendo sobre la
situación que ocurre una de las
explicaciones tiene su origen en el
confinamiento donde billones de personas
quedaron en sus casas y empezaron a
utilizar el comercio electrónico como
una manera para adquirir bienes
obligó al uso de los pocos medios
logísticos que quedaron funcionando y
como era de esperar redujeron las
existencias de mercancía y productos
elaborados que estaban disponibles por
otro lado la publicación final se han
time señala que tras la pandemia y la
puesta en marcha de la reactivación
económica se ha mantenido una alta
demanda por un lado al tiempo que cuando
china uno de los mayores de exportadores
logró controlar el brote y reactivó su
producción como parte de la recuperación
económica tomó desprevenidos a muchos
países que además de no haber controlado
el brote no estaban preparados en la
cadena logística en francia 24
conversamos con el profesor de
operaciones y logística global de la
universidad de georgetown en eeuu y esto
fue lo que nos dijo respecto a la
situación el mundo entero tiene un flujo
de productos que va desde china hasta
europa pasando por los eeuu todos un
flujo continuo de productos lo que está
sucediendo es que hay un bloqueo si hay
una faltante muy grande de contenedores
todos los productos se mueve por
contenedores de atrayente estadística el
90% el 90% de todo lo que se mueve en el
mundo a través de barcos por mar
entonces cuando tienes estas trabas
estos cuellos de botella tan grandes y
la falta de contenedores pues
definitivamente hay una ruptura en la
cadena abastecimiento que es lo que está
generando este problema ahora luisa
incluso otras causas que pueden impactar
y agravar aún más esta situación verdad
por supuesto que si esta situación si
bien está afectando a muchos países en
el mundo ha tenido sus aristas más
visibles en eeuu y reino unido en el
caso de eeuu la situación ha colapsado
los principales puertos del país como lo
son el puerto de los ángeles y el de
long beach ambos ubicados en el estado
de california estos de acuerdo con datos
de la agencia de noticias aps que cita a
fuentes del terminal marítimo reciben
alrededor del 40 por ciento de los
contenedores que llegan a eeuu y hasta
el jueves 13 de octubre previo al
anuncio del presidente joe pairing había
cerca de 64 buques fondeados en sus
cercanías esperando para descargar
mercancías ante la situación como ya
adelantábamos el gobierno estadounidense
tomó algunas medidas como negociar la
extensión en los horarios de los
principales puertos escuchemos
quiero ser claro este es un compromiso
generalizado de ir a las 24 horas los 7
días de la semana es un gran primer paso
para acelerar el movimiento de
materiales y mercancías a través de
nuestra cadena de suministro pero ahora
necesitamos que el resto de la cadena
del sector privado también se sume el
reino unido- también uno de sus
principales puertos como lo es el de
felixstowe y ha mostrado atascos para el
desembarco y salida de contenedores de
acuerdo con una publicación del diario
español elmundo muchos buques que iban
en dirección a ese puerto debieron ser
trasladados a otros para evitar un mayor
congestionamiento del terminal británico
en ese país la situación desde el punto
de vista de los opositores a la
administración de boris johnson responde
a una falta de preparación a la salida
del reino unido- de la unión europea
allí el gobierno también ha tomado
medidas para hacer frente a la situación
louis ahora una pregunta clave que surge
en todo este contexto tiene que ver con
cómo se afecta a los ciudadanos toda
esta crisis por supuesto que hay una
alta demanda que se incrementó y se ha
mantenido desde la pandemia y por ello
se ha visto un ansia en lo que respecta
al índice de precios al consumidor o
mejor conocido como la inflación pero
esta es una de las causas más visibles
pero además existen otras que de acuerdo
con los especialistas podría presentarse
en el futuro y tiene que ver con los
recortes en la producción de algunas de
las principales empresas por ejemplo la
empresa apple anunció que reducirá en
hasta 10 millones de unidades su
producción del nuevo teléfono iphone 13
debido entre otras cosas a la escasez de
chips adicionalmente la empresa
automotriz toyota informó que reducirá
en 15 por ciento su producción para el
mes de noviembre también por la escasez
de chips y los problemas energéticos que
se presentan en algunas localidades de
china gracias por una nueva completísima
crónica de materia económica de nuestra
agencia limitamos a 'continuar
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación siguen con
[Música]